to warn in the disk scrape does match
with all the season 8 leaked photos so
before we continue keeping in mind that
this might be an actual season 8 script
so let's just jump in dead
it's a sir senior earner having a
conversation in the throne room there
alone sir she sits on the Iron Throne
and urine stands before her your says
throughout my life I've experienced many
dangers I travel to a shine sale the
smoking sea evoke the smoking ruins of
Valyria the most recent experience was
more dangerous than all the previous
ones combined the Warriors won I want
what's been promised to me
Cersei replies the war is not one you
might have brought huge casualties the
dragon queen and her pet Norton but
urine interrupts certain states what's
left if anything is left of them does
not represent the threat to the crown
anymore
the war is won sir supplies but it's not
every single soldier you and the golden
company slew is not part of the army of
the Dead then a king's army grows
stronger day by day I promise to give
him my hand the Devi emerged victorious
in the throne is safe did I not with
every search his spoken word urine grows
more and more angry let me stop right
there to point out that he has allegedly
defeated John snow in Daenerys Targaryen
your says his mana warrant search the
supporters claim by praising his
accomplishment of defeating the quote
dragon Queen her pet nor Turner does
this mean urine will interrupt John and
then his fleet that is sailing towards
North that's most likely not the case
several months ago is so interval
burning down to the ground I believed it
was the night Kings doing however in the
leaked photos from the very same battle
we also saw the dead greater soldiers we
all thought it could be that Theon would
manage to savior and then go back to
Winterfell to help John protect it does
the phone greater soldiers with this
league scripted might have nothing to do
with Fiona in the air after all it might
have something to do with their unclear
as it seems like he might attack the
inside while they're preparing for the
Great War
long story short what this slick script
seems to be claiming is that urine
instead of bringing the gun and company
to King's Landing has actually brought
him to the north or upon the surprise
attack John and Aeneas forces at
Winterfell and he allegedly brought
massive casualties to them the Fallen
greater soldiers would be those under
urines command or in another words your
own schedule teased the craziest thing
about a slick script is that it could be
true and might have even been
foreshadowed in a previous season let's
take a look on the following clip it's
the greatest mother Westeros has ever
seen with the iron fleet you owned the
seas you can defeat the invaders and
east and the pretenders in the north and
south what do you want in return
ever since I was a little boy I wanted
to grow up and marry the most beautiful
woman in the world so here I am for a
thousand ships and two good hands your
promise that with his help she could
defeat invaders in the east and the
pretenders in the north and south you're
not already delivered one of his
promises by defeating Yara and the sand
snakes and it seems that he might
fulfill other parts of it as well Joran
also describes his experiences more
dangerous than traveling to a shy
sailing the smoking sea and walking the
smoking ruins of Valyria combined could
it be that someone else might have
joined a battle between urine and John
and Danny the night king might come in
the heat of a battle with his undead
army taking the advantage of the
opportunity while the living fight among
themselves before I continue with the
League scriptlets also point out your
statement quoting a travel tour shy and
sail the smoking sea I walk the smoking
ruins of Valyria is something that your
northen brags about in the books anyways
let's continue with the script the
script says urine comes a bit closer to
Cersei and says I'm not your stupid
brother you can't manipulate me we had a
deal to marry once the war against the
Crown's traitors is won I won that war I
only want what's been promised to me she
takes a deep breath and before she could
answer your Epps's sends about her pale
white throat and starts choking the life
from her your says where's your monster
friend to protect you now huh or your
boyfriend brother
Cersei tries to fight but can do much
sir she tries to talk but it's not able
to do so with your sands choking her
yearned and says perhaps I don't need to
marry after all all I have to do is kill
you and take the throne by myself Cersei
somehow manages to whisper the golden
company will kill you your smiles and
stuffs choking Cersei PST's what will
the golden company do huge laughter from
urine follows but only for a few seconds
urine and suddenly appears to be angry
again urine States you think the golden
company will stand against me I'm the
one who signed the contract with them
I'm the one who brought them here and
I'm the one who led them into battles
they're loyal to me not you
matter of fact homeless Harry already
suggests
meet overthrow you you have no soldiers
you have no gold
you're no Queen before Cersei could
reply to that Qyburn enters the throne
room your own glances at the Crown's
maester who nods to his Queen Cersei
then goes on to say thank you for all
your help your own Greyjoy but as of now
our allegiance is over with Cersei nods
back to Qyburn the scene then switches
to the streets of King's Landing where
people are spreading panic regarding the
night king and his army there's much
going on in the script including the
valonqar prophecy was coming true and
the gun companies seemingly between
Cersei while kyburi answers is not
there's something huge to look into
valonqar is high Valyrian for little
brother the term is used by Maggie a
fortune teller from lens port when
making a prophecy to Cersei quoting and
when your tears have drowned you the
valonqar shall rapid sense about your
pale white throat and choke the life
from you however even though it seemed
like urine could be the prophesied
well-anchored that will put an end to
Cersei as it turns out he's not urine
eventually stops choking Cersei
indefinitely does not kill her regarding
home is Harry that your claims has
supported him over Cersei he's the
current captain commander of the golden
company his name is Harry Strickland but
due to the very nature of the golden
company he's chosen the nickname home is
Harry
additionally this character has actually
been casted for season eight of the
supporting slick script even more the
most intriguing part of the script
however is its ending Otto Qyburn
answers is not Smee
ask I burn perhaps nodding to Cersei
that mountain is ready to kill urine on
her command or is he perhaps nodding to
heard that the pyromancers are ready to
initiate the Wildfire attack whatever it
is Cersei nods back to it giving it the
green light so whatever it might be it's
going down I also received one more
script page this one allegedly being
from episode three and it finally sees
the wedding of Ice and Fire
this script starts with the guise of a
Winterfell it's night John and any hold
hands as they stand side by side before
the sacred we would Hartree it says the
settin precedes the tie ribbon in a knot
around their joint hence it symbolizes
their union I hereby seal these two
souls binding them as one for eternity
cursed be those who would seek to tear
them apart Septon says set on continuous
look upon each other and say the words
Johnny Denny look upon one another and
star reciting their vows both of them
speaking simultaneously say father Smith
warrior mother maiden Crone stranger -
they're still speaking simultaneously
johnandannie recite their main vows John
says I'm her son she's mine from this
day until the end of my day
and the near says I'm his and his mind
from this day until the end of my days
finally after the Worcester finished
Yankees is Danny
if this script page turns out to be true
episode three of the final season will
finally witness the long-expected
Targaryen marriage I know that this
script might cause some confusion among
viewers since John and Danny seem to
have a fate of seven style wedding
ceremony this should not be surprising
since era star himself married Kathleen
in the fate of 7 style wedding so did
Robin Talisa
however in closer inspection it seems as
if John's and Danny's wedding is a
hybrid of the fate of the seven and old
God's wedding ceremonies it's not
performed in a Sept at all but it seems
to be held in a local God stood in front
of a virile tree
additionally fate of the same wedding
ceremonies are typically held during a
day well John and Dana's wedding is
seemingly held at night which is
actually how old God style wedding
ceremonies are conducted this leaked
script is actually very similar to the
one I received a couple of months ago
with the only difference being that the
older one also sees a marriage between
yearn and Cersei anyways the marriage of
Ice and Fire has been long anticipated
and if these scripts are to be believed
episode 3 will finally stir the love
this however is not coming as a huge
surprise take into account that Danny's
most likely pregnant with John's baby
and John on the other hand would never
allow his child to be born out of
wedlock both the Targaryen baby and the
Targaryen marriage have been held for
shadow throughout the previous season
the dis varying regardless of the script
being real or not it's something that's
most certainly happening in the final
season you're not like everyone else
and your family hasn't seen its end
you're still here I can't have children
who told you that
the witch you were mad at my husband has
it occurred to you she might not have
been a reliable source of information in
my previous video I introduced a theory
in prediction in which the final season
of Game of Thrones will not see one but
two royal weddings one between John and
Danny and the other between gentry and
Arya both of these variants have been
heavily hinted and foreshadowed in both
the show and the book series that are
likely to happen in less season of Game
of Thrones it's been in your family for
centuries it's not right for me to have
it he gave it to you I know his son
I brought shame into my house it broke
my father's heart I've forfeited the
right to claim this soul
it's yours it serve you well your
children after you if you're interested
in all the clothes and foreshadowings
that are pretty much confirming these
weddings coming true make sure to check
out my recent videos there you have guys
allegedly script for season 8 episode 5